joining us also now to react to the
president's Oval Office address to the
country tonight South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham senator Graham you met
around Congress a bit of time and both
in 2006 you were around when the secure
Fence Act was passed to build 700 miles
of wall which never happened in 2013
they allocated 46 billion dollars for
border security 8 billion to build and
repair and reinforce barriers at the
border and I'm listening to Senator
Schumer and congresswoman Pelosi say
this is a manufactured crisis would you
say that to police officer Singh's
family tonight or Pierce Corcoran's mom
and dad that were on this program last
night or the families of victims of four
thousand homicide families would you say
this is manufactured it couldn't be more
real to them this is the most
presidential I've seen president Trump
it was compelling and everything he said
was true about 30 percent of the 22
hundred miles of border has some form of
barrier there are already walls along
the border we just need to extend those
walls where it makes sense but one thing
we have in common is a member of the
Senate speaker of the house minority
leader of the Senate and president
United States we have a bunch of people
guarding us with guns it's pretty hard
to get in the Capitol really hard to get
in the White House all the president's
saying is I'd like to provide more
security to the American people it is a
crisis shine I've tried to be reasonable
and practicable when it comes to
immigration and I'm flabbergasted to
hear from my Democratic colleagues who
have voted for billions of dollars in
border security money that this is
manufactured was it manufactured when
Obama wanted the money no why don't you
give the money to Obama and Bush if it
was a manufactured crisis well and I
think if you look Hillary Clinton
supported it Chuck Schumer supported it
Biden supported Obama supported it we
have had in the last two weeks really
high-profile incidences one is officer
saying there
the other is this young man his parents
were on this show last night
Pierce Corcoran died illegal immigrant
killed him in a drunk driving accident
and the question here is when you add to
that human trafficking the drug traffic
night and you add to that the violence
at the border and let's assume 98% of
people across the border which I believe
are people that want more freedom and
opportunity right but we got to ask
ourselves how many lives are how do you
if we lose 4,000 lives in the two-year
period is that a manufactured crisis -
my Democratic friends
how many caravans have to rush the
border but until you believe we have a
problem we have 300,000 people waiting
for asylum claims to be adjudicated
we have 11,000 unaccompanied minors from
Central America it costs us 750 dollars
a day to house and only god knows what
they go through to get here illegal
immigrations on the rise because our
policies are attracting people here
every Democrat you heard from tonight
has voted for border security but when
it comes to Trump they say no so Nancy
Pelosi says in the shutdown Donald Trump
says secure the border how about this
let's secure the border then in the
shutdown let me ask you senator it seems
to come down to their argument is and I
know it is inconvenient for those
furloughed employees knowledge and I can
sympathize with them I know their checks
are going to be delayed in some cases
and but it's a partial government
shutdown essential services are up and
running and that constitutes what
two-thirds to 70% of the government
stays open and I do want these people
that have been furloughed to get back
money etc but the point is if the
president doesn't take the stand here
fully do you see any other path that he
can use that he will get the money to
stop the crimes from happening on our
southern border the drug trafficking
human trafficking some criminal elements
that want to cross over our border I've
been dealing with this since 2006 this
is the best chance I've seen to get a
deal the president made a compelling
case tonight for more border security
and I think he
is right to ask for more money to secure
a border as to the government employees
I'm sorry I'm sorry you're in the middle
of this mess but you'll get your back
pay you're going to be fully compensated
missing is not going to get our husband
back to all those people have lost loved
ones from illegal immigration your loved
ones are not coming back
so I'm bound to determine to see this
thing through there should be a deal
where we secure the border give the
president the wall money he needs and
try to fix other problems like DPS
reform and maybe do something for the
daca population there's a deal to be had
here but it's hard to get a deal when
people you're dealing with call you a
racist because you want a border
security wall give you a dollar and say
that's enough a huge Border Patrol
agents of gassing children when mobs run
toward our border we're dealing with
pretty radical people here and we're
never going to get a deal until the
radicals are set to the side and we get
reasonable people to deal with you know
especially considering that it was
supported by Democrats in the past
you're making a good point here if
people want to as we know abolish ice
Kamala Harris actually said to the head
of ice Tom Holman suggested that now
well you know there's a perception that
ice is at least in people's minds
perceived as the Ku Klux Klan right
right I was pretty stunned that we would
talk about wave law enforcement that way
but we also watch these officers get
pelted with rocks and models yes on two
occasions during the migrant caravan and
on New Year's Eve the bottom line is
this this is the question I think we
need to ask tonight will the wall work
in Yuma Arizona the sheriff said it
works it works every time it's been
tried well it works in Israel I can tell
you I've been dealing with Boris
security issues for 10 years plus every
time we build a physical barrier the
drug trafficking goes down the illegal
crossings go down there are some places
you don't need a physical barrier but
there's 700 miles of fencing has been
authorized since 2006 we just want to
build what we've already agreed to do
and so the bottom line is walls work but
you're dealing with a group of people
who see their government as the problem
they see the border
agent as the problem not the mob they
see the ice agent is the problem not the
illegal immigrant they're trying to go
after they see walls that already exist
is a moral excuse me immoral you know
what I think is immoral is to accuse
people trying to defend the nation
honestly and working hard and putting
their lives at risk of being the problem
and not the coyote not the drug dealer
not the terrorist
so if Democrats want to fight they're
going to get one if they want to solve
the problem we'll do that too it seems
if we and I want to know where your
fellow Republican senators stand here
because if the argument of the Democrats
is this is a manufactured crisis well
that goes against the number of
homicides in that two year period and
and sex offenses that have taken place
in that two year period and violent acts
against Americans in that two year
period then the drug and the human
trafficking the question is here we're
talking about on the one hand we're
gonna have some people that work for our
government that are inconvenienced
I am sympathetic than I'm sorry about
that yes me I'm also sympathetic to the
parents that were on this program last
night I'm sympathetic to the five-month
old little boy of a police officer in
California that will never see his
father for the rest of his life and I'm
sympathetic to the victims of crime are
your fellow Republicans willing to say
life and death is more important than a
delayed paycheck and inconvenience I
hope Republicans will remember like most
Democrats you voted for twenty five
billion dollars for border security
funding in February of 2018 if it was
not if it's a manufactured crisis
Senator Schumer speaker Pelosi why did
you vote for a board security package
less than a year ago that had twenty
five billion dollars for border security
including wall money to my Republican
colleagues this is the best chance we'll
ever have to help President Trump gets
border wall funding still barrier
funding and at the same time fix the
loopholes the only way we lose is to
give in if will stand firm put deals on
the table that makes sense we will win
this on behalf of the American people
but if we undercut the president that's
the end of his presidency
at the end of our party and we deserve
to be punished if we give in now in
other words as long as it takes you
believe you and your fellow senators are
willing to stay and fight to stop drugs
human trafficking and criminal activity
from the small percentage of people that
cross our border because it's unsafe and
not secured before the end of this week
I intend to put legislation together
that has wall funding like the president
has requested and argued that we voted
for the same thing in the past before he
was president and tend to put legal
reforms on the table that we've all
voted for I intend to help the TPS
population about 400,000 people going to
lose their legal status now I'm willing
to entertain legal status for the DREAM
Act population that we've all voted for
so what am I going to do I'm going to
take bills we've all voted for and see
if they can be voted for under Trump the
problem is not the policy the problem is
that my Democratic friends don't
acknowledge a president Trump won that's
the problem all right senator Graham
thank you for being with us tonight